[Musik]
Phoenix vor Ort
ja herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren wir unterbrechen unser Programm
denn der Machtkampf zwischen dem
Söldnerführer prigoschin und der
Militärführung in Moskau spitzt sich zu
prigoshi dessen Söldner eine wichtige
Rolle im Krieg gegen die Ukraine Spielen
hatte sich gestern offen gegen die
russische Militärführung gestellt und
ist in die russische Region Roßdorf am
Dornheim marschiert über den
messenger-dienst telegram teilte
Gregorian mit alle militärischen
Einrichtungen in Rostock sein
mittlerweile unter seiner Kontrolle ja
Pregarten wirft dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister schollufuhr
Angriffe auf die Lager der wagnertruppe
angeordnet zu haben und erfordert nun
Verhandlungen mit dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister und dem
Generalstabschef gerassimo daran scheint
die russische Seite allerdings nicht
interessiert zu sein wir hören der
russische Geheimdienstes SFB ermittelt
gegen pregorian und in mos und Region
wurden
anti-terrormaßnahmen in Kraft gesetzt
das russische
Verteidigungsministerium rief die
Kämpfer der wagnertruppe auf sich von
prigoschen abzuwenden ja und an meiner
Stelle auch noch mal ein herzliches
Willkommen 10 Uhr Moskauer Zeit heute
morgen ca 9 Uhr hier in Deutschland dann
eine Rede des russischen Präsidenten im
Staatsfernsehen Putin sprach in seiner
Rede von Hochverrat von einem Verbrechen
von einem Dolchstoß der sich gegen das
ganze russische volkwände und zu Beginn
seiner Rede wiederholte er das
altbekannte narrativ russland werde vom
ganzen Westen bekämpft das kennen wir
mittlerweile dass er aus seinem eigenen
Angriffskrieg eine Art
Verteidigungskrieg macht und den
allgemeinen besten zum Täter wir hören
die Rede des russischen Präsidenten von
heute morgen
ich wende mich an die Bürger Russlands
an die Truppen
an die Rechtsschutzorgane und
Sicherheitsdienste angekommandeure und
Kämpfe die gerade an der Front im
Einsatz sind
machen ich weiß darüber ganz genau heute
Nacht zu habe ich mit den allen
Befehlshaber gesprochen ich wende mich
an diejenigen die ihr durch die Lüge
oder Betrug in einer verbrecherische
Avant Türe
hineingezogen sind und die auf den Weg
die haben Meuterei getreten sind heute
steht Russland im schweren Kampf für die
Zukunft sie werden Aggression der
Neonazis und ihrer Herren ab gegen uns
ist praktisch die ganze Maschinerie des
Westens Gerichten die Informationen die
Wirtschaft und die sicherheitsmaschine
okay das heißt es wir kämpfen für unsere
Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit für
unser Recht Russland zu sein und zu
bleiben Start mit dem mit der
1000-jährigen Geschichte und heute ist
natürlich die Einigkeit gibt gefragt die
Konsolidation und die solidarision soll
ich da rede heute müssen wir alles
beiseite legen die uns schwächt alle
Quelle leihen die von unseren
außenfeinden ausgenutzt werden um uns
von inneren so Schwächen deshalb alle
Handlungen die uns Schwächen das ist
eigentlich die Abtrünnigkeit von eigenem
Folge von Kameraden an der Front das ist
ein Stich in den Rücken gegen unser Volk
und unser Heimat genauso
kam es im Jahr 1917 als unser Land im
Weltkrieg stand und als Russland der
Sieg gestohlen worden wurde also der
Verrat
führt
zum Zerfall der Staates und zum
Verzicht auf riesen Territorien und im
Endpunkt änderte sich alles im
Bürgerkrieg als die Brüder die Brüder
getötet haben und profitieren dafür
haben nur die ausländischen Feinde die
unser Land aufteilen wollten wir lassen
das nicht zu dass er sich wiederholt wir
werden unsere Heimat von allen Gefahren
verteidigen darunter von der
von dem inneren Vertrag das was wir
jetzt zu tun haben das ist eben der
Verrat die
ausufernden
Ambitionen führten schon Verrat an dem
Volk und an den Kameraden an der
Frontlinien die Helden von
don't was unterstüm auf konsolida die
Kämpfer von Wagner die ihr Leben
abgegeben haben im Kampf in der Ukraine
und dieser Menschen sind auch verraten
verraten worden von diejenigen die die
Menschen jetzt zur Treulosigkeit bewegen
noch mal
jede
innerlicher wäre ist tödlich gefährlich
für uns als eine Nation das ist ein
unser Volk und Nation und unsere
Handlungen zum Schutz der Nation und der
Heimat werden hart sein alle diejenigen
die bewusstlos die mörderei vorbereitet
haben durch die terroristische Maßnahmen
und die auspresst und die Erpressung
werden sowohl vor dem Volk wie auch vor
dem Gesetz verantwortlich müssen die
Streitkräfte unter anderem Staatsorganen
Organe haben notwendige Befehle bekommen
die zusätzlichen Maßnahmen zur
sicherheitssicherung sind in Moskau in
Region Moskau sowie ein anderen Regionen
des Landes getroffen wurden
zusätzliche Maßnahmen werden in Bezug
auf die Stadt Rostow am Donner getroffen
werden die Lage dort bleibt immer noch
kompliziert die Arbeit der zivil und
Militärbehörden sind dort blockiert
worden und als stadtpräs werde ich alles
tun um die Verfassungsordnung das Leben
und ihre Freiheit der Bürger in Schutz
zu nehmen die Organisatoren und strecken
sie ja der Meuterei diejenige die die
Waffe gegen die die Kameraden gerichtet
haben haben das Land für raten und
werden dafür verantwortlich müssen
die anderen Anrufe ich auf keinen
tragischen Fehler zu begehen und
einzig möglicher Entscheidung zu treffen
die Beteiligung an den gesetzwidrigen
Handlungen einzustellen ich bin fest
überzeugt wir werden unser Land
verteidigen wir werden alle
Herausforderungen meistern und werden
noch stärker
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler der
Universität Köln ist mir zugeschaltet
guten Tag Herr Jäger einen schönen guten
Tag Frau Dauster ja die Rede Putins
werden wir auch gleich noch einordnen zu
Beginn aber die Frage die irgendwie über
allem steht und nämlich die Frage hat
Putin auf den falschen Mann nämlich
rigorcin gesetzt
das ist schwer zu sagen wir haben das in
der Vergangenheit ja so interpretiert
das brigochien durch seine Ausfälle
gegenüber schon gut und gerassimo auf
dem politischen und militärischen
Führern in der in Russland den
Handlungsspielraum von Putin erweitert
insofern als er immer gesagt hat die
sind schuld dass es hier nicht zu
erfolgen kommt die schaffen es nicht
genügend Munition und genügend Truppen
heran zu bekommen die schaffen es nicht
ein ausreichendes Führungsverhalten an
den Tag zu legen und das hat Putin die
Möglichkeit gegeben sich sozusagen an
die Seite zu stellen und es hätte einen
Sündenbock gegeben den gibt es ab jetzt
nicht mehr jetzt ist wirklich Putin für
diese Misserfolge zuständig denn er hat
sich klar hinter schon gut und gar nicht
aufgestellt und hat das Waschen macht
eben als hoch Verrat bezeichnet hatte
auch eigentlich gar keine andere
Möglichkeit nachdem über Wochen
vorbereitet durch seine Reden eine einen
Angriff letztlich im Informationsraum
auf Putin der die ganze Geschichte von
der Bedrohung durch die Ukraine von dem
Verteidigungskrieg Russlands einfach zu
dem macht was es in Wahrheit ist nämlich
nichts man stellt sich jetzt die Frage
ist prigoschin stark genug wir wissen
seine seine soldat-truppe ist ungefähr
25.000 Mann stark im Vergleich dazu die
russische Armee 1,3 Millionen Soldaten
davon 840.000 aktiv der Rest in Reserve
also wer nimmt es hier
größenverhältnismäßig mit wem auf
naja die Frage die wir noch nicht
beantworten können weil darüber hat
brikoshi noch nicht gesprochen ist wie
gut ist das vorbereitet man kann sich ja
nicht vorstellen dass das sozusagen aus
einer Laune aus einem Zorn heraus
geschehen ist und wenn er das gut
vorbereitet hat so wie die zumindest
seine Maßnahme im Informationsraum das
möglich sein lassen dann hat er
möglicherweise ein weiteres Netzwerk
über 30.000 ehemalige Wagner Kämpfer
Strafgefangene die jetzt in Russland
frei leben möglicherweise hat er auch
Kontakt zu anderen aufgenommen die über
Privatarmeen verfügen wie kadur auf etwa
aus Tschetschenien der jetzt zwar sagt
er steht an der Reihe an der Seite
Putins gegen diesen Durchstoß aber da
wird sie im Hintergrund sicher jetzt
ganz viel verhandelt wer kriegt was für
was denn das konnte man Putin reden ja
nun wirklich entnehmen da herrscht Angst
es geht jetzt um die Macht im Kreml und
Putin weiß dass er die Lage nicht mehr
kontrolliert und die große Frage ist hat
er die Sicherheitskräfte im Griff oder
hat brigoche möglicherweise irgendwelche
Angebote die dann die Soldaten zu ihm
überlaufen lassen denn das ist die
militärische Führung nicht tun wird das
ist richtig aber er könnte ja darauf
spekulieren die Kriegsmüdigkeit der
russischen Soldaten zu nutzen indem er
etwa verspricht den Krieg zu beenden
weil er auf diese Art und Weise nicht
gewonnen werden kann ja sie haben es
erwähnt also es könnte eventuell oder
entscheidend wird jetzt wohl sein wer
sich alles auf die Seite von prigosh ihn
schlägt sie haben den Tschetschenen
kadiros genannt Gazprom das Unternehmen
Gazprom hat auch ein oder zwei
Privatarmeen gegründet und wir wissen
alle dass es um die Moral der russischen
Soldaten auch nicht besonders gut
gestellt war
ist das jetzt so eine etwas wie ein
kriegsentscheidender Moment obwohl wir
noch nicht wissen wie er ausgeht aber
wie könnte es sein nur es kommt darauf
an für welchen krieg jetzt gibt es ja
auf einmal zwei auf der einen Seite für
Russland einen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine um dort Gebiete zu besetzen und
auf der anderen Seite gibt es jetzt in
Russland militärische
Auseinandersetzungen die man sehr wohl
als Krieg unterschiedlicher Streitkräfte
bezeichnen kann denn es gibt inzwischen
Gefechte zwischen den Wagner Söldnern
und den russischen Truppen also
sozusagen Truppen die brigochien
gehorchen und Truppen die schon gut
gehorchen und das wird man sehen müssen
wie das in den nächsten Tagen jetzt
ausgeht sicher wird das eine Lage sein
die sich relativ schnell entscheidet die
Rückwirkungen auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine die lassen sich noch nicht
wirklich absehen außer dass man jetzt
schon sagen kann das ist eine für die
Ukraine vorteilhafte Situation denn
Kampf erfahrene Soldaten sind dort
abgezogen worden und für die Herrschaft
im Kreml steht ab jetzt an allererster
Stelle und hat Priorität die Macht im
Kreml zu sichern also es könnte ein
günstiger Moment sein für die Ukraine
weil sich jetzt natürlich der Fokus der
der russischen Streitkräfte erstmal auf
einen anderen Feind sozusagen richtig
wie die Ukraine diesen Moment nutzen
wird werden wir sehen lassen wir uns
noch mal über die Lage in Moskau
sprechen der russischen Hauptstadt dort
sind jetzt Terror Anti terrormaßnahmen
in Kraft gesetzt was bedeutet das
tatsächlich in der Umsetzung im Alltag
was erleben die Menschen jetzt dort in
Moskau
ja zum ersten ist im Stadtbild überall
sind Sicherheitskräfte zu sehen und zwar
unterschiedliche Art von der
Geheimdiensten Polizei
Militär und das Moskau gesichert wird
auf jede erdenkliche Art und Weise das
war ja zuvor schon zu beobachten man
wird jetzt sehen müssen ob brigoche in
eine Strategie hat wie er weiter vorgeht
dass die seine Truppen jetzt auf dem Weg
sind nach Moskau und etwa die halbe
Strecke hinter sich gebracht haben bevor
sie als erste Mal auf Widerstand
gestoßen sind hat eine Lage hergestellt
in der sie ist nun wirklich auf die
Frage ankommt wie gut ist das alles
vorbereitet dass die russische Seite auf
solche aber eine solche Maßnahme nicht
vorbereitet war das sieht man ja allein
schon dadurch dass es ihm gelang eben
eine große Stadt direkt einzunehmen und
das Kommando Süd sozusagen unter seine
Gewalt zu bringen
also jetzt wird man aber relativ schnell
in Russland reagieren und sehen dass man
die Sicherheitsorgane aufgestellt
bekommt ja also Sie haben es erwähnt
also mittlerweile hören wir dass selbst
eine bewaffnete Einheit in Baronesse
eingetroffen sei das ist ungefähr 500
Kilometer von Russland entfernt also
vielleicht noch sechseinhalb Stunden bis
man die Hauptstadt Moskau erreicht also
es wird auf jeden Fall ein spannender
Nachmittag früher Abend noch werden um
zu sehen wie sich die Lage dort
entwickelt jetzt haben wir gehört Putin
hat in oder der russische Geheimdienst
es FB ermittelt gegen pregorien ihm
sollen bis zu 20 Jahre Haft drohen aber
dazu wird es ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht
kommen sollte man ihn fassen oder wie
schätzen Sie die Lage ein
nein er hat jetzt sozusagen die Anklage
wegen Hochverrat im Rücken er hat selbst
gesagt dass man bereit sei hier zu
fallen in diesem Waffengang den er
begonnen hat das wird sicher mit Gewalt
entschieden und
möglicherweise
ist das sozusagen ein Prozess der
relativ schnell geht wenn es denn
russischen Truppen gelingt sich
entsprechend aufzustellen das könnte
sich aber eben im Land auch noch je
nachdem welche
sozusagen Resonanz es findet ganz anders
darstellen
Jäger bis hierhin wir sprechen gleich
noch einmal wir hören jetzt aber erst
noch mal einen ein Statement vom Chef
der wagnertruppe Söldner nämlich von
prigoshi
wir befinden uns im Stab der sonder für
Operation ist der 7.30 unter unserer
Kontrolle sind alle militärko Objekte in
Rostow darunter auch der Flughafen da
hat die Militärflugzeuge die an der
Frontlinie im Einsatz sind setzen ihre
Arbeit fort sowie auch die
sanitätsflugzeuge das einzige was wir
gemacht haben also die Kontrolle
übernommen damit die Militärflugzeuge
nicht uns sondern die Ukraine angreifen
die
Leitungsorgane der Streitkräfte der
Arbeit sind wie gewohnt die jeder
Offizier ist am Arbeitsplatz und
wir stören die Arbeit der Stadt nicht
und als
als wir hierher gekommen sind müssen wir
feststellen er norbertätorien sind
verloren worden enorm
Menschen in Massen sind verloren worden
um mehrfach mehr als offiziell bekannt
gegeben wird die sanitätsverluster pro
Tag machen manchmal bis
1000 Menschen aus das sind die getöteten
die Verwundeten und die Verweigerer es
mangelt an Munition und es mangelt an
der Leitung die Menschen sind in der
gastgasse der Chef des Stabs ist
geflogen worden sofort erfahren hat dass
wir uns dem Gebäude nähern
so das war der Chef der Söldnertruppe
wagnerin der sich in der Vergangenheit
wir haben darüber gesprochen ja immer
wieder auch mit dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister schon gelegt hatte
oder sich beschwert hatte auch mit dem
Generalstab Chef jetzt aber offenbar
richtet sich der Kampf direkt gegen den
Präsidenten gegen den russischen Staat
sozusagen oder
ja das hat sich gestern angedeutet als
in langen Stellungnahmen eben eine
völlig ganz eine völlig andere
Darstellung der Ursachen dieses Krieges
gegeben hat als das Präsident Putin Tat
und da war sichtbar dass hier an Bruch
erfolgt ist und der große Schritt war
dann eben nicht nur auf telegram
irgendwelche Reden zu veröffentlichen
das war schon Provokation genug aber in
dem Moment in dem man eben den ersten
Panzer startet und losfährt und die
Richtung moskau ist in dem Moment waren
die würfelge gefallen und standpräsident
Putin unter dem Zwang sich eben so
äußern zu müssen weil seine Herrschaft
jetzt gefährdet ist denn das ist ja so
Russland befindet sich im Krieg
Präsident Putin erzählt seiner
Bevölkerung die ganze Zeit dass der
gesamte Westen Russland zerstören wolle
was völliger uns ist um das gleich dazu
zu sagen und er ist nun der
Oberbefehlshaber der die Lage nicht in
unter Kontrolle hat Putin ist die
Situation entglitten wir sehen hier
nebenbei Bilder aus Moskau ganz aktuelle
Bilder der Situation wir sehen dass
Straßen gesperrt sind rund um den
Präsidenten Palast wir haben gehört dass
anti-terrormaßnahmen in Kraft gesetzt
wurden Moskau die Hauptstadt Russlands
wird also geschützt vor einem womöglich
bevorstehenden Einmarsch bewaffneter
Truppen oder Gruppen der der
Söldnergruppe Wagner Herr Jäger lassen
Sie uns noch mal auf die Rede von
Präsident Putin schauen die ihr heute
Vormittag 10 Uhr russischer Zeit in
russischen Staatsfernsehen gegeben hat
sie haben es angesprochen sein narrativ
der Westen greife Russland an das ist
ein altbekanntes und ein falsches
darüber haben wir haben das haben Sie
auch schon
deutlich gemacht und gleichzeitig haben
wir in dieser Rede auch ähm Worte wie
Deutsch gestoßen gehört also eine eine
Rhetorik die an den ersten weltkrieger
erinnert und die Frage an Sie
ob wie stark oder schwach sie Präsident
Putin in dieser Rede wahrgenommen haben
ist völlig in die Ecke gedrängt der hat
die Lage nicht unter Kontrolle eine
solche Rede will niemand halten der
seine Streitkräfte gegen ein anderes
Land gewendet hat und das wird ja in der
Bevölkerung völlig deutlich wahrgenommen
dass hier eine Situation entstanden ist
in der
Kämpfer die die ganze Zeit als
diejenigen dargestellt wurden die so das
russische narrativ wiederum heldenhaft
Gebiete befreit haben sich auf einmal
gegen das eigene Land drehen und das
muss Präsident Putin jetzt versuchen
sozusagen einzufangen er tut das in dem
er sagt da sind sozusagen einzelne die
aus
Karrieregründen aus am Egoismus die
diese Verbrechen begehen die sich über
das Land Stellen ich glaube nicht dass
er damit durchkommt und sozusagen den
Wechsel schafft von einer einem einem
Lob dieser Söldnertruppe
die einen hohen Blut soll in dem Krieg
bezahlt haben hin zu einem jetzt
sozusagen zur hassadoren zu Verrätern
die auf Moskau marschieren da ist eine
große Kluft die muss er erklären und er
kann sie nicht erklären danke Herr Jäger
für diese Einschätzung und ihre Analyse
danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
ja der Machtkampf zwischen dem
Söldnerführer prigoschin und der
Militärführung in Moskau spitzt sich zu
kriegerstein hatte die sich gestern
offen gegen die russische Militärführung
gestellt und ist in die russische Region
Roßdorf einmarschiert wir werden das
ganze natürlich weiter beobachten und
werden sie um 13 Uhr auch noch mal hier
informieren über die aktuellen
Geschehnisse über neue Informationen wir
werfen jetzt aber noch einmal einen
etwas genaueren Blick auf diese
Söldnertruppe Wagner und auf den man
dahinter rigoshi
viel ist über die russische
Söldnergruppe Wagner nicht bekannt sie
wurde 2014 gegründet für den Kampf in
der Ostukraine seitdem sollen
wagnereinheiten in etwa 30 Ländern im
Einsatz gewesen sein unter anderem in
Syrien und Mali laut britischen
Geheimdienst befehle ich die
wagnergruppe bis zu 50.000 Kämpfer in
der Ukraine rekrutiert werden vor allem
ehemalige russische Soldaten und
zunehmend auch Strafgefangene die dafür
Amnestie erhalten seit vergangenem Jahr
tritt der Oligarch gfgeni brigorcin
offiziell als Chef der wagnergruppe auf
den Söldnern wurden immer wieder
Kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen in der
Ukraine sollen sie an den Gräueltaten
von Butcher beteiligt gewesen sein so um
13 Uhr also neues von uns hier bei
Phoenix vor Ort jetzt geht es erstmal
weiter mit einer Doku die sich mit dem
Untergang der Sowjetunion befasst bis
später machen sie es gut
[Musik]